you're very active on social media
yeah just posted a pic lately what is
this this is laid-back Sunday this is
you took this selfie nicest looking
selfies i've ever seen thanks no mean
it's like I don't even know how you got
your hand it's it's it was a bit awkward
I do awkward selfies that's standing it
looks like it's later that's Dan but you
you yeah and you'd posted just me mouth
just you and your Calvin's what was the
inspiration for that for doing that
James Franco yeah see you know if you
actually look in the paper magazine
article you know with you know Kim
Kardashian breaking the internet inside
of that if you keep going there's like a
whole calendar that James Franco did of
just pure selfies every month has a
selfie and then every day of each month
has a selfie and you know he had written
an article that I'd read about the art
of the selfie and for like the
Huffington Post and has like I really
got to start doing some selfies some
more I got to kind of catch up with that
cuz you know I'm always posting like
really inspirational quotes and you know
all these things about the different
organizations that I work with and I was
like you know maybe that's a good way to
kind of get some of those things in and
be like me and my Calvin's go though me
and my Calvin's 1 billion rising you
know it's this way it kind of just mix
it up a little bit right exactly you
just do what you want people to draw
people in and then give them a good
message yeah that's what I mean that's
what I get a lot of times when I'm doing
you know interviews like he buttered me
up right he buttered me up a little bit
he said not at all no kind of sweet talk
to me a little bit I do the same thing
to use a little flirtation thing oh you
weren't being sincere I'm not with
totally sincere fine yeah like you know
I kind of get a thing on you
it's just this idea you know this thing
that we do we stay with stuff how you
doing and then you like get into the
serious you know we got into the serious
selfie conversation this relates to top
five because in top five you play a
reporter yeah you get very close to
Chris Rock's character and you do flirt
with him and it and it what you both are
you're both flirting with each other but
you can see that there's a sexual
tension there it made me wonder if you
ever I mean that's part of even
interviewed so many times magazines
newspapers people doing articles do you
find that yourself ever flirting to just
make that part go better do you know
what I mean no I feel like that goes
totally the other way around
like I've seen so many situations where
I've got in there and people like talked
to you and they like what are you up a
little bit some of the organizations or
things that I really love so much and
then they'll go I just have to ask these
questions my editor told me it's really
stupid they're really bad fit I'm so
sorry and then you ask you these
questions and then the entire article is
that and it makes me seem like really
shallow or like silly or something like
that but it's like but it kind of sucks
sometimes and I'm always like you know
it's okay if you just want to ask me
like some fluff questions just ask me
the fluff questions and then we can save
an hour I can go have lunch with my
friend like you know I have found over
the years that that that always happens
just me when they're taking a photograph
they always say what's gonna be they get
me like a cool jacket or something and
they get this really great lighting and
they say we they take 800 of those and
then they say just as I'm headed out the
door they're like can we just get one
where you're naked in a litter box no
it's like yeah we're not even gonna use
it and I'm like okay just go in there
and I'll do it and click that's the
cover of litter box magazine
oh it's always like something oh yeah
yeah yeah that's the one that they
always go with you're like we're all the
cool moody life well they're like yeah
you're not that good-looking that's what
I get
you